The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
CHARLES LEISERSON: It
is my great pleasure
to welcome Jon Bentley,
now retired from Bell Labs.
Jon was my PhD thesis
supervisor at Carnegie Mellon.
I actually had two supervisors.
The other one was HT Kung,
who is now at Harvard.
I guess people flee Carnegie
Mellon like the plague
or something.
So Jon is, as you
know because you've
studied some of his work, is a
pioneer in software performance
engineering.
And he's going to talk today
about a particularly neat piece
of algorithmic
engineering sets that
centers around the so-called
traveling salesperson problem,
which is an NP-hard problem.
NP-complete problem in fact.
And so, without further
ado, Jon, why don't you
tell us what you've got to say?
JON BENTLEY: As
Charles mentioned,
I want to talk with you--
I want to tell you a story
about a cool problem.
This is a problem that I first
heard when I was a young nerd--
not much older than this little
pile of nerds in front of me--
in high school, the traveling
salesperson problem.
Who here has heard of
the TSP at some point?
I heard about this in high
school, one of the things
you read about it
in the math books.
And a few years later, I
had a chance to work on it.
In 1980, I was doing
some consulting,
and I said, well, what you
need to do is solve a TSP.
Then I went home and
realized that all
of the stuff that I learned
about it was sort of relevant
but it didn't solve
the problem, so I
started working on it then.
Our colleague,
Christos Papadimitriou,
who's been at Berkeley
for a long time
after being at a
lot of other places,
once told me the TSP
is not a problem.
It is an addiction.
So I've been hooked for
coming up on 40 years now.
And I want to tell you one story
about a really cool program I
wrote.
Because this is one of the--
I've been paid to be a computer
programmer for coming up
on 50 years, since I've been
doing it for 48 years now.
This is probably the most
fun, the coolest program
I've written over a
couple day period.
I want to tell you a story.
Start off with what
recursive generation is.
Then the TSP, what it is.
Then I'll start
with one program,
and we'll make it faster
and faster and faster.
Again, I spend my whole
life squeezing performance.
This is the biggest
squeeze ever.
And then some
principles behind that.
We'll start, though,
with how do you enumerate
all the elements in a set?
If I want to count--
enumerate the guys between 1
and a hundred, I just count.
That's no big deal.
But how can I, for
instance, enumerate
all subsets of the set from
the integers from 1 to 5?
How many subsets are there
of integers from 1 to 5?
AUDIENCE: 2 to the 5.
JON BENTLEY: Pardon me?
JON BENTLEY: 2 to the 5, 32.
But how do you say
which ones they are?
How do you go through
and count them?
Well, you have to decide
how you represent it.
You guys know all about
set representations.
We'll stick with bit
vectors for the time being.
An iterative solution
is you just count--
0, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, up to 31.
That's pretty easy.
But what does it mean to count?
What does it mean to go from
one integer to the next?
How do you go from a given
integer to the next one?
What's the rule for that?
It's pretty easy, actually.
You just scan over all the
0's, turning the-- you start
at the right-hand side, the
least significant digit,
scan over all the
0's, turn it to 1.
Oh, I lied to you.
You scan over all the
1's, turning them to 0
until you get to the first 0.
And then you turn that to a 1.
So this one goes to 10.
This one goes to 11.
This one goes-- that one
becomes 0, that one becomes 0.
Then it becomes 00100.
So a pretty easy algorithm.
You could do it that way.
Just scan over all
the 1's, turn them
to 0's, take that first
one and flip it around.
But that doesn't
generalize nicely.
We're going to see a method
that generalizes very nicely.
This is a recursive
solution to enumerate all 2
to the n subsets
of a set of size n.
And the answer is this
all sets of size m
is just put a 0 at
this end, enumerate
all sets of size m minus 1.
How many of these will there be?
2 to the m minus 1.
How many of those
2 to the m minus 1?
What do they add up to?
2 to the m.
But all of these have
the 0 at that end,
and the one at that end.
Everyone see that recursive
sketch and how that works?
Here's the example.
A period with 0's at this
end and you fill it out.
You have the 1 at that
and you fill that out.
If you do that, you
notice that in fact we're
just counting backwards--
000, 001, 010, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7.
That's the algorithm.
And the cool thing is the
code is really simple.
I could probably write a program
like that in most languages
and get it correct.
So if m equals 0 in generate
all subsets of size m,
this doesn't occur at 1.
You have a pointer
going down the array.
Otherwise, set the
rightmost bit to 0,
generate all subsets
recursively, set it to 1,
do it again recursively.
That's a starting program.
If you understand
this, everything else
is going to be pretty
straightforward.
If you don't, please speak up.
One thing that-- you
people have suffered
the tragedy of 14 or 15 or 16
years of educational system
that has sort of beaten
the creativity out of you
and you're afraid to speak up.
So even if something-- even
if I'm up here spouting
total bullshit, you'll
ignore that fact and just
sort of politely
stare at me and nod.
But this is important.
I want you to understand this.
If you don't understand this,
speak now or forever hold it.
Anyone have any questions?
Please, please.
AUDIENCE: What does
mean, [INAUDIBLE]??
JON BENTLEY: I'm sorry.
Why did we set p to the--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JON BENTLEY: So here, first I
go out to the extreme rightmost
and I set it to 0.
Then I recursively
fill those in.
Then I change it from a 0 to a 1
there, and I fill all those in.
So this is a program
that will go through,
and as it enumerates
a subset, it
will call the visit procedure
a total of 2 to the m times,
then it comes down to the
bottom of the recursion.
Thank you, great question.
Any other questions
about how this works?
OK, we'll come back to this.
The traveling
salesperson problem.
I apologize.
I will really try to say the
traveling salesperson problem,
but I will slip because I
was raised with this being
the traveling salesman problem.
No connotations, no
intentionality there,
just senility galloping along.
It's a cool problem.
Abraham Lincoln faced this
very problem in the years
1847 to 1853 when he--
everyone here has heard
of circuit courts?
Why do they call
them circuit courts?
Because the court used
to go out and ride
a circuit to go to a
whole bunch of cities.
Now people in the cities
come to the court.
But back in the day, in
1847 to 1853, Lincoln
and all of his homies
would hop on their horses--
a judge, defense lawyers,
prosecutors-- and go around
and ride the circuit here.
And so this is the actual
route that they rode where they
wanted to do this effectively.
It would be really stupid
to start here in Springfield
and go over there,
then to come back here,
then to go over
there back and forth.
What they did was
try to find a circuit
that minimized the total
amount of distance traveled.
That is the traveling
salesperson problem.
We're given a set of n things.
It might be a general graph.
These happen to be in the plane.
But you really-- helicopter
service was really bad
in those days, so they didn't
fly there from point to point.
Whether they stayed on roads,
what really matters here
is the graph embedded in here.
I'm going to speak at this.
Everything I say will
be true for a graph.
It will be true for geometry.
I'll be sloppy about that.
We'll see interfaces, how
you handle both, but just cut
me some slack for that.
I have actually face this
myself when I worked on a system
where we had a big
mechanical plotter
and we wanted to draw
these beautiful maps where
the maps would fill in dots.
They happened to be precincts.
Some of them were red,
some of them were blue.
And you wanted to draw all the
red dots first and go around
here.
And, in fact, the plotter
would draw this red dot,
then that red dot, then
this one, then that one.
The plotter took an
hour to draw the map.
I was consulted on this.
Aha, you have a traveling
salesperson problem.
I went down.
I reduced the length to about
1/10 of the original length.
If it took an hour before,
how long would it take now?
Well, it took
about half an hour.
And the reason is that the
plotter took about half
of its time moving around
about, 30 minutes moving around,
and about 30 minutes
just drawing the symbols.
I didn't reduce the time
drawing the symbols at all,
but I reduced the time
moving things around
from about 30 minutes
to about 3 minutes.
That was still a big difference.
So I fixed it there.
When I worked at
Bell Labs, we had
drills that would go
around, laser drills,
move around on printed
circuit boards to drill holes.
They wanted to move it that way
I talked to people at
General Motors at one point.
On any day, they might
have a thousand cars
go through an assembly line.
Some of the cars are red, some
are white, some are green,
some are yellow.
You have to change the paint.
Some of them have V6,
some of them have V8.
Some of them are two doors,
some of them are four doors.
In what order do you
want to build those cars?
Well, every time you
change one part of the car,
you have to change the line.
And what you want
to do is examine,
as it were, all n factorial
permutations of putting
the cars through and choose
the one that involves
the minimum amount of change.
And the change from
one car to another
is a well-defined function.
Everyone see how that
weird TSP is in fact a TSP?
So all of these
are cool problems.
Furthermore, as a
computer scientist,
it's the prototypical problem.
It's the E. coli of
algorithmic problems.
It was literally one
of the first problems
to be proven to be NP-hard.
Held-Karp gave a polynomial
time algorithm for it.
There are approximation
algorithms of this.
Kernighan-Lin have
given heuristics.
It's a really famous problem.
It's worth studying.
But here is what
really happened to me.
Here's why I'm standing
in front of you
today talking about this.
My friend Mike Shamos,
in his 1978 PhD thesis
on computational
geometry, talked
about a number of problems.
One of them was the TSP.
And he shows us and he gives
an example of this tour.
He says, here's a
set of 16 points.
Here's a tour through them.
Here's a traveling
salesperson tour through them.
And then he says in
a footnote, in fact,
I'm not sure if it's
a really optimal tour.
I applied a heuristic
several times.
I'm not positive it's
the shortest tour.
If you wrote a
thesis, it would be
sort of nice to know
what's going on there.
Can you solve a
problem that was--
this tiny little
16-element problem,
16 points in the plane.
Can you really figure out
what the TSP is to that?
At the time, my colleague, our
colleague, a really smart guy,
couldn't do it.
It was computationally
beyond the bounds for him.
Well, in 1997 I
came back to this,
and I really wondered
is it possible now?
Computers are a whole lot
faster in the 20 years.
We were talking about
that earlier today.
20 years, computers got faster.
A lot of things got better.
Have things changed
enough so I can
write a quick little
program to solve this?
I don't know.
We'll see.
I did that.
I talked about it.
I gave a talk at Lehigh
University 20 years ago.
They liked it.
They incorporated it
into an algorithms class.
The same professor gave it
time and time and time again.
Eventually, he retired.
They asked me to come over
and give this talk to them.
I can't give a talk about
20-year-old material.
Computer science
doesn't work that way.
So I coded things.
I wanted to see how things
changed in two years.
So this talk is about
a lot of things,
but especially it's
about how has performance
changed in 40 years.
So that's one of the
reasons we were--
one of things we were
talking about earlier today.
I could give a bunch of
titles for this talk.
For you, the title
I give is a sampler
of performance engineering.
It could be-- next week
I'll give it at Lehigh.
This is their final class in--
one of their final classes in
algorithms and data structures.
I'm going to try to tie
everything they learn together.
It could be all
these other things--
implementing algorithms, a
lot of recursive generation,
applying algorithms, really--
Charles is a fancy
dancy academic.
He's a professor at the
Massachusetts Institute
of Technology.
I'm just a poor dumb
computer programmer,
but boy this is a fun program.
What it is not is it's not
state-of-the-art TSP algorithm.
People have studied the problem
for well over a century.
They have beautiful algorithms.
I am not going to
tell you about any
of those algorithms
for the simple reason
that I don't know them.
I could look them up in books,
but I've never really lived
the fancy state-of-the-art
algorithms.
And I'm also going to just
show you getting the answer.
I could analyze it.
I've analyzed much of these.
If I had another hour or
three, I could do the analysis.
But I can't, so I'm
just going to do the--
show you some anecdotal speeds
without really the analysis.
Let's talk about some programs.
A simple C program.
MAXN is a maximum
number, n int is going
to be n, the number of cities.
I'm going to have a
permutation vector, where
if I have the tour going
from city 1 to 7 to 3 to 4,
it says 1734.
The distance between
cities is going
to be given by a
distance function.
There is this
distance d of i, j,
the distance from
city i to city j.
Here's the first algorithm.
What I'm going to do is generate
all intact real permutations,
look at them, and
find the best one.
It's not rocket science.
The way I'm going to do
this is a recursive function
where I happened--
I could have done it
from left to right.
I am a C programmer.
I always count down towards 0.
So I'm going to count down that
way, where all of these cities
are already fixed.
I'm going to permute these.
Here's the program.
To search for m--
all of these have
already been fixed.
What I'm going to do is if
m equals 1, then I check it.
Otherwise, for i equals 0 up
to m, for each value from 0
to minus 1, I take
the ith element.
I swap it.
swap 3, 7 takes the third
and seventh positions
and swaps them.
I swap that to the final thing.
I call it recursively.
I then swap it back to leave
it in exactly the same state I
found it, and I continue.
So here it's going to generate,
first, all nine permuta--
put all nine digits
in the last position.
Then for each one
of those, I'll put
all eight digits in the last
position, and go on down.
This is really interesting,
important, and subtle.
If you don't follow this part,
it's going to be difficult.
Are there any questions
at all about this?
Have I lied to you
yet about this?
You're honest enough
to tell me if I have.
AUDIENCE: You're good.
JON BENTLEY: Thank you.
Anyone else?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JON BENTLEY: I'm sorry.
Please.
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
I'm not really understanding
the part that's fixed
and what you're permuting,
and why is that hard to fix.
JON BENTLEY: So, so far,
as I recur down with--
as m moves down,
all these are fixed.
So I'm going to
fix these things,
and then I'm going to take
care of all these later.
So, originally, I'm going
to have this array be
0-- if I have a nine-city TSP,
it will be 0, 1 2, 3, 4, 5, 6,
7, 8, 9.
And first I put 0 in
the end and do the rest.
Then I put 1 in the end,
[INAUDIBLE] 9 in the end,
and recur down.
But as the program
is progressing,
if you stop the
program at any time
and look at a glance
at the program,
you can see that, given the
value of m, this parameter,
the recursive function.
So this is a way
that I'm essentially
building this tree where
at the top of the tree
the branching factor is 9.
At each of those nine
nodes, the branching factor
is 8, then 7 and 6.
It's going to be a big tree.
If n is 10, how big is
that tree going to be?
What's 10 factorial?
Pardon me?
When I was a nerd,
we used to try
to impress people of
appropriate genders
by going off saying
things like 3628800.
You can probably guess
how effective that was.
So 3.6 million.
It's going to be a big tree.
Any questions about that?
Let's go.
When I check things, I
just compute the sum there.
I start off with the sum
being the distance from 0
to p n minus first.
Then I go through and add
up all the pairwise things
and save it.
What does it mean to say it?
If the sum is less than
the minimum sum so far,
I just copy those over,
change the minsum.
And to solve the whole thing,
I do a search of size n.
This is a simple but
powerful recursive program.
You should all feel very
comfortable with this.
Is it correct?
Does it work?
Is it possible to
write a program
with about two dozen
lines of code that works?
Not the first time.
But after you get rid of a few
syntax errors, you check it.
How do you make sure it works?
I start with n equals
3, and I put 3.
Does it give me a tour?
Well, it works.
Think about it.
For 3, 3 factorial,
they're all the same tour.
That part wasn't hard.
4, now that's interesting.
That one works too.
This program, in fact, can work.
Is it going to be
a fast program?
How long will it
take if n equals 10?
How many seconds?
I'm sorry.
What class have I stumbled into?
Is this in fact Greek Art 303?
How long will this
take for n equals 10?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JON BENTLEY: Pardon me?
AUDIENCE: 1 second.
JON BENTLEY: About a second.
Pretty cool.
For equal 20, how
long will it take?
A lot longer.
Technically speaking, it's
going to take a boatload longer.
So what I'm going to
do here is-- notice
that there are n
factorial permutations.
You do n of those at
each, total of that,
on this fairly fast laptop
from a few years ago.
But now they're
all about the same.
At 8 seconds, it took that.
At 9 seconds, what should
be the ratio-- what would
you expect to be the ratio
between its time at 8
and time at 9?
Well, about a factor
of 9, you'd hope.
Is 0.5 times 9 about 0.34?
Yes, close enough.
Here, going down, for 10
it's 4 seconds, 46 seconds.
Yes, it's going up by a factor--
so here I've run
all my examples.
I ran out to 1
minute of CPU time.
After that, I estimate.
If this one takes
3/4 of a minute,
12 times that is 12 minutes--
3/4 of that is 9 minutes.
For 13, it's 2 hours.
How long should
14 take, ballpark?
A day, ballpark.
How long will 15 take
if 14 takes a day?
AUDIENCE: Two weeks.
JON BENTLEY: Two weeks.
How long will 16 take?
Eight months.
You get the idea.
Are you going to go
out to 20 for this one?
No.
Are you going to go out
to 16 with this one?
Can you just put this
into a thesis right now?
No.
The problem is it's fast for
really small values of n.
As it becomes bigger--
how can you make
the program faster?
If you wanted to make
this program faster,
what would you do?
What are some ideas?
Give me some ideas, please.
This is performance engineering.
You should know this.
Ideas for making it faster.
Please.
AUDIENCE: You can start
with arbitrary nodes.
So if you take the tour, you
can start anywhere, right?
JON BENTLEY: OK.
So you're saying
just choose one start
and ignore that,
ignore all the others.
You don't need to take
each random start.
Fantastic.
A factor of n.
My friend in the gray T-shirt
just got a factor of n.
How else can you make it faster?
What ideas do you have?
Please.
AUDIENCE: You can
start by the distance,
and then reject things
that were [INAUDIBLE]..
JON BENTLEY: Be greedy.
Follow the pig principle.
If it feels good, do it.
Do just local optimization.
We'll get to that
in a long time,
but, boy, would that be
a powerful technique.
Other ideas, please?
AUDIENCE: Parallelize
[INAUDIBLE]..
JON BENTLEY: Ah.
Parallelize.
I would write that out, but
the first I would have to do
is remember how many R's and
L's there are in various places.
So I'll write that much.
But we'll have a comment
on that at the end.
People tried that.
Sir?
AUDIENCE: Clock the machine.
[STUDENTS LAUGH]
JON BENTLEY: Unlike you,
Charles and I, at one point,
attended a real
engineering school
at Carnegie Mellon,
formerly known as CIT,
Carnegie Institute
of Technology.
Charles, do you
remember the cheer?
CHARLES LEISERSON: The cheer?
JON BENTLEY: The cheer.
CHARLES LEISERSON: I
don't know how to cheer.
JON BENTLEY: 3.14159,
tangent, secant, cosine, sine.
Square root, cube
root, log of e.
Water-cooled slipstick, CIT.
What's a water-cooled slipstick?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JON BENTLEY: Pardon me?
JON BENTLEY: It's a slide
rule that you run so fast.
It has to be water-cooled.
So if you can just
overclock the machine,
just spray it with
a garden hose.
And as long as it makes
over the finish line,
you don't care if it
dies when it collapses.
So, sure, you can
get faster machines.
We'll talk about that.
How else can you
make this faster?
Other ideas?
These are all great ideas.
We'll try it.
Let's see some ideas.
Compiler optimizations.
I just said gcc and I ran it.
What should I have said instead?
Instead of just gcc?
AUDIENCE: O3.
JON BENTLEY: O3.
How much difference
will that make?
I used to know the
answers to all these.
[INAUDIBLE] turn on
optimization, 10%.
Sometimes,
whoopee-freaking-do, 15%.
Does turning on O3 still
make it a 15% difference?
We'll see.
You could do that.
A faster hardware.
I did this 20 years ago.
I had all that number there.
I'll show you some
of those numbers.
Modify the C code.
We'll talk about
all those options,
but let's start with
compiler optimizations.
With no options there--
how much faster will
it be if I turn on optimization?
This is a performance
engineering class.
You should know that thing.
Does it matter at all?
Is it going to be 15%?
Is it going to
not matter at all?
How much will it matter
to turn on optimization?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] a lot.
JON BENTLEY: How much is a lot?
I know this isn't the real
engineering school of CIT,
but pretend like this
is kind of a semi--
one of the engineering schools.
Give me a number for this.
AUDIENCE: More than 15%.
JON BENTLEY: More than 15%
Do I hear more than 16%?
I was surprised.
If I enabled O3, it went
from 4 seconds to 12--
I couldn't even time it here.
It wasn't enough
to time it here.
45 seconds to 1.6 seconds.
I can get real times down there.
I observed, ballpark here,
about a factor of 25.
Holy tamale.
On a Raspberry Pi, it
was only a factor of 6,
and on other machines it was
somewhere between the two.
Turning on optimization
really matters.
Enabling that really matters.
For now on, I'm only going to
show you full optimization.
It's cheating not to.
But just think about
that, a factor of 25.
How else can I make if faster?
Two machines.
Back in the day, I happened to
have some data laying around
of running it on a Pentium
Pro at 20 megahertz.
Nowadays, I had this.
How much faster will this
machine be 20 years later?
Again, pretend like you're
at a real engineering school.
What will it be?
Please.
AUDIENCE: 20 times faster?
JON BENTLEY: 20 times faster?
How did you get 20 times faster?
AUDIENCE: Well, the clock
speed is 10 times faster.
JON BENTLEY: The
clock speed about 10.
AUDIENCE: But I'm
guessing that it
has much better instructions.
JON BENTLEY: Here's
what I found.
On this machine, it
went from a factor--
there is about a hundred--
these factors, I
found, consistently
were about, over the 20
years, about a factor of 150.
From Moore's law,
what would it be
if you had 20 years if
you doubled every two?
That's 10 doublings.
What is 2 to the 10th?
AUDIENCE: It's a thousand.
JON BENTLEY: A thousand.
So Moore's law
predicts a thousand.
It's more than a factor of 20.
I got a factor of
150 here, which
is close to what Moore's
law might predict,
but there is some
slowing down at the end.
I'm not at all
traumatized by this.
A speed-up of about a factor of
150, where does that come from?
My guess is you
get about a factor
of 12 due to a faster clock
speed, and another factor of 12
due to things like
wider data paths.
You don't have to try
to its cram everything
into 16-bit funnel.
You have 64-bit
data paths there.
Deeper pipelines, more
appropriate instruction
sets, and compilers that
exploit those instruction sets
if O3 is enabled.
If O3 is not enabled,
sucks to be you.
Questions about that?
Let's go.
So we have constant
factor improvements,
external, modern machines,
turn on optimization.
But a factor of 150 and
a factor 25 is a lot.
We were starting off with that.
That is a good start.
Back in the day, if you change
things from doubles to floats,
it got way faster.
From floats, the
answer was faster yet.
Does that change make
much difference nowadays?
No.
Exactly the same runtime.
One thing that does
make a difference
is-- this is the definition
of the geometric distance.
My j is the square root
of the sum of the squares
of the differences.
That's doing an array access, a
subtraction, a multiplication,
multiplication, two array
accesses, subtraction,
multiplication, addition,
and a square root.
That used to take a long time.
If I replace that
with a table lookup
by filling out
this sort of table,
the distance for
algorithm 2 is just
the distance arrays of i sub j.
That gave me a speedup
factor of 2 and 1/2 or 3.
Back in the day, that was
a speedup factor of 25.
For you as
performance engineers,
you have all this intuition.
Every piece of intuition
you have, that I had,
that was really appropriate 10
years ago is irrelevant now.
You have to go back and
get models to figure out
how much each thing costs.
But, still, it's another
speedup factor of 3 just
by replacing this arithmetic
with a table lookup.
Algorithm 3.
What we're going to do is choose
the ones we need to start with.
So we'll start at city 1.
We'll leave 9, if we
have a 9-element problem,
in that position, and
just search of n minus 1.
It doesn't matter
where you start.
You're going to go back
to it, so you can just
choose one to start with.
Not a lot of code.
Permutations are now
that, distance at each.
So now you've reduced n times
n factorial to n factorial.
Algorithm 4 is I'm computing
the same sum each time.
Is there a way to avoid
computing the same darn sum
each time?
We'll carry that
sum along with you.
Instead of recomputing the same
thing over and over and over,
start off with the sum being 0.
The parameters are now m and
the distance so far. s Then you
just add in these remaining
pieces at each point,
and you solve it that way.
And there it's sort of a
nice piece of mathematics.
I wish I had the
time to analyze it.
I did a spreadsheet where I
said, what's the ratio of this?
And it started off as 3, 3
and 1/2, 3.6, 3.65, 3.7--
3.718281828.
What does that mean if you
see a constant 3.718281828?
It's 1 plus e.
And once I knew
what the answer was,
even I, in my
mathematical frailty,
was able to prove that it's
1 plus e times n factorial.
I'm not giving you the
proof, but it's very cool.
You run across these things.
So here are the four
algorithms so far.
On an entirely different
semi-fast machine,
the runtime--
here the real clock
times on this machine
were 10, 11, 12, 13.
Real times in bold
are measured times.
These other times are
approximate estimates.
And you can see now
that for size 13,
you go from taking a
fraction of an hour to taking
a third of a minute.
We've made some programs faster.
That's pretty cool.
We feel good about this.
This is what we do.
Any questions at all?
We got to go faster.
How do we go faster?
To say precisely, for
all these experiments,
I took one data set.
And if I say that
runtime for size 15,
I take the first 15
elements of that data set.
For 16, I take the
first 16 elements.
17, and so on and so forth.
It's not great science.
I've done the experiments
where I did it
on lots of random data.
The trends are the same.
It smooths out some of the
curves, but we'll see this.
The times are for initial
sequence of one random set.
It's pretty robust.
But the problem has factorial
growth. it started factorial.
It's still factorial.
What does that mean?
Each factor of n allows us to
increase the problem size by 1
in about the same time.
Faster machine and all that,
we can now push into the teens.
What does that mean?
You can take Abraham
Lincoln's problem,
and they got a tour
with this length.
The optimal tour looks sort
of the same on this side,
but it's really
different over here.
Charles, what figure is that?
I've mentioned yesterday that
if you work on the traveling
salesman, every instance you
see turns into a Rorschach test.
CHARLES LEISERSON: The first
one is a bunny hopping,
and the second one is just
the head of the bunny.
JON BENTLEY: The bunny head.
Everyone see that?
Those are in fact
the correct answers.
He is a psychologically
sound human being.
Does anyone else want to
give their Rorschach answers?
A free diagnosis.
Absolutely no charge.
I'll completely diagnose
you. but the bunny hopping
and the bunny head are in fact
the correct answers for here.
We'll see more later.
So Abraham Lincoln, you've
solved his problem now.
My friend Mike Shamos
could solve his problem.
Did he get the optimal tour?
Well, over here he
got a big part of it.
But over here it's really
sort of a different character.
It's a fairly
different character.
Is it far off?
Yes, about a third
of a percent off.
So his approach was within
a third of a percent.
I've always worked--
I spent much
of my career working on
approximate solutions to TSPs.
Those are often good enough.
This algorithm, you can
prove-- that he applied--
is within 50%.
In the real world, it got
within a third of a percent.
Wow.
But now we can go out and we
can solve the whole problem
in 16 hours.
If you were writing the thesis
and you happened to do this,
would it be worthwhile now
to sink 16 hours of CPU time
into this?
You're going to go
away for a weekend
and leave your machine running.
At the time,
Charles, when we had
one big computer for 60 or
70 people in that department,
could we have dreamt about
using 16 hours for that?
On the very border.
If you made it a really
mellow background process,
it might finish in
a week or three.
All of these things change.
The computers get faster.
They get more available.
You can devote a machine
to dump 16 hours down this.
But can we make it faster yet?
Can we ever analyze,
say, all permutations
of a deck of cards?
How many permutations are
there of a deck of cards
if you take out those jokers?
What's that number?
AUDIENCE: 15 zeros?
JON BENTLEY: 1 with
15 zeros after it?
It's a big number, 2 to the--
52 factorial.
I want to teach you how
big 52 factorial is.
People say, that problem
is growing exponentially.
What does that mean?
It's quick is what people
usually mean by it.
In mathematics, it's
some constant to the n
for some defined time period n.
Factorial growth-- is factorial
growth exponential growth?
Why not?
Why isn't a factorial
exponential?
AUDIENCE: It's more
than exponential?
JON BENTLEY: It's
more than exponential.
It's super exponential.
We'll talk about
the details here.
By Sterling's approximation,
you have seen in other classes
that log of n factorial is n
log n minus n plus O of log
n for the natural log.
The log base 2 of n factorial
is about n log n minus 1.386n.
Where have you seen
this number before?
n log n minus 1--
In an algorithms class, you
did a lower bound on a decision
tree model of sorting.
There were n factorial
leaves to sort.
A sort algorithm must take
at least as much time.
So that gives you that bound.
And merge sort is n log n minus
n, so you're really narrow.
Where else have you seen 1.386n?
That's the runtime
of quick sort.
All these things are
coming back together here,
because it's the
natural log of e--
I'm sorry-- the log base 2 of e.
So n factorial is
not 2 to the n.
It's 2 to the n log n.
It's about n to the n.
It's faster than any
exponential function.
How big is 52 factorial?
You guessed 10 to the 15th?
Was that--
AUDIENCE: Yes.
JON BENTLEY: OK.
If we see here, it's going
to be something like 2
to the n log n.
n is 52.
Log of 52 is about six.
So that's 2 to the 300.
But there's a minus n term.
Maybe 2 to the 250.
It's about 2 to the 225,
which is 10 to the 67th.
That's a big number.
How big is it?
Let me put it in everyday terms.
Try this after class.
Set a timer to count down
52 factorial nanoseconds, 10
to the 67th.
Stand on the equator--
watch out where you are--
and take one step forward
every million years.
Don't rush into this.
I don't want you to get
all hyper about this.
Eventually, when you
circle the Earth once,
take a drop of water
from the Pacific Ocean,
and keep on going.
Be careful about this.
But this is an experiment.
You're nerds.
It's OK.
When the Pacific Ocean
is empty, at that point
lay a sheet of paper down,
refill the ocean, and carry on.
Now keep on doing that.
When you're stack of
paper reaches the Moon,
check the timer.
You're almost done.
This is how big
10 to the 52nd is.
The age of the universe
so far is about 10
to the 26th nanoseconds.
10 to the 52nd is a long time.
Can we ever solve a problem
if we look at all 10
to the 52nd options?
What do we have to do instead?
AUDIENCE: Quantum computing?
JON BENTLEY: Pardon me?
AUDIENCE: Quantum computing.
JON BENTLEY: Quantum computing.
OK.
That's great.
And I have a really cool bridge
across this river out here
that I'll sell you after class.
Let's talk about that.
Is there a nice quantum
approach to this problem?
Maybe.
Maybe you could actually phrase
this as an optimization problem
where you could maybe get
some mileage out of that.
But we'll see.
So one approach is
quantum computing.
What's another approach?
What are we going to have to
do to make our program surmount
this obstacle?
Please.
AUDIENCE: Limit
the search space?
JON BENTLEY: Pardon me?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JON BENTLEY: We're going to
have to limit our search space.
We're going to have to
prune the search space.
That's the idea.
Let's try it.
Here's a cool problem.
I was at a ceremony
a few weeks ago.
A friend of mine said
here's this cool problem
that his daughter just
brought home from high school.
How do you solve it?
Find all permutations
of the 10 integer--
the nine integers
1 through n such
that each initial substring
of length m is divisible by m.
So the whole darn thing
is divisible by 9.
Is any permutation of integers
1 through 9 divisible by 9?
Well, they all sum up to
numbers divisible by 9.
You work that.
Is it divisible--
are the first eight
characters divisible by 8?
But let's start
with an easy one.
If you were doing it
for size 3, 321 works.
Is 321 divisible by 3?
Is 32 divisible by 2?
Is 3 divisible by 1?
Thinking, then, it works.
Is 132 divisible by 3?
Yes.
Is 13 divisible by 2?
[MAKES BUZZER SOUND]
That doesn't work.
So we're going to try
to solve this problem.
My friend Greg Conti, a really
great computer security guy,
gave me this problem.
How do you solve it?
How would you
solve this problem?
If this high school
kid says, here's
a problem I brought home from
school, how do I solve it?
What would you do?
Ideas?
I'm sorry.
Please.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
You could write a program where
the state could be [INAUDIBLE]..
Or actually just like
a subset [INAUDIBLE]..
Then you iterate
over [INAUDIBLE]..
JON BENTLEY: Great.
So there are two
main approaches.
One is write a program.
So you can either think
or you can compute.
Who in this room enjoys
writing programs?
Who enjoys thinking?
Oh, that's an easy call.
What's the right approach here?
Well, the right answer
is you think for a while.
If you solve it in the
first three minutes,
don't write a program.
If you spend much more
than five minutes on it,
let's write a program and see
what we learn from the program.
We'll go back and forth.
Never think when you
should compute, never
compute when you should think.
How do you know which one to do?
Try each.
See which one gets
you further faster.
If you write a
program for this, What
are the basic structures
you have to deal with?
You have to deal with
nine-digit strings that
are also nine-digit numbers.
What's a good language
for dealing with that?
What would you-- if you had
to write a program to do this,
what language would you choose?
We'll see.
How do you generate all
intact real permutations
of the string?
Well, I hope you can see this.
Here's the way that
I chose to do it.
I chose to have a
recursive procedure search.
And I'm going to have right be
the part that's already fixed,
left be the part that
you're going to vary.
I could've done
it the other way,
but I'll choose
to do it this way.
I start with left equals
that, right equals that.
I end when the left is empty.
So I have to recur down, just
like we've been doing so far,
but I'm going to do that
with strings instead.
And if I get to the call search
of 56-- of 356 with 421978--
these are all fixed--
I'll take each one of
these in turn, 3, 5, and 6,
put it into here.
So I'll call search of 56
with that, search of 36
with that, search
of 35 with that.
Everyone see how that works?
How long will the code be
in your favorite language?
Here's the code in
my favorite language.
Has anyone here ever used
the AWK programming language,
written by Aho,
Weinberger, and Kernighan?
They observed that
naming a language
after the initials
of the authors
shows a certain
paucity of imagination.
But it works.
So a function search
of left, right,
that, if left equals 0--
is null, I'll check it.
Otherwise, what will I do here?
The details don't matter.
For i equals 1 up to the
length of the left-hand side
of the string,
search the substring
at the left starting at
1, going for i minus 1,
concatenated with the
substring at the left
starting at i plus 1.
And then take the
substring in the middle,
put it out in
front of the right.
Do that for all i values.
Any questions about that?
The details don't matter.
It's not a big program.
If I do this, and at the
end, for i equal 1 to length,
if the substring of the right
mod i is nonzero, then return.
If it's not that,
you print it out.
If I run this program,
how long, ballpark,
will this program take
for 9 factorial, ballpark?
What was your answer before?
AUDIENCE: A second.
JON BENTLEY: A second.
Great.
Well, we'll recycle that.
Reduce, reuse, recycle.
We'll recycle your answers.
If I call it originally
with that string,
it takes about 3 seconds.
And it found that there
was-- it searched all 9
factorial, 362880,
362,000 strings,
and found only one string
there that matches that.
Whoops.
Are these divisible by 9?
Well, they sum to a
multiple of 9, sure.
Is the string that ends
in 72 divisible by 8?
Yes, that works.
7, I'm not going to bother with.
All the way down, is
38 divisible by 2?
Is 381 divisible by 3?
This one works.
That's a pretty cool problem
for a high school afternoon.
Is 3 seconds fast enough?
Yes.
The trade-off of
thinking and programming.
Write the darn program.
You're done.
It's cool.
If you wanted to make it faster,
how could you make it faster?
That's what this
course is all about?
Always think about how you
could make things faster.
Please.
AUDIENCE: Well, if you just
stop searching once you know
one number isn't going to work.
JON BENTLEY: How early
can you stop searching?
That's great.
So you could get
constant factor speedups.
Like don't check for
divisibility by 1 at the end.
You can change
language, all that.
But those are never
going to matter.
The big win is going to come
from pruning the search.
How can you put in the search?
Any winning string must have
some properties of this string.
What are some properties
that that string has
that you can check for early?
Please.
AUDIENCE: The second from the
left [INAUDIBLE] 2, 4, 6 or 8.
JON BENTLEY: The eighth position
has to be a multiple of 2.
Furthermore, if you
really think about it,
you can get more than that.
It has to be divisible by 4.
So an even number has to
be in the eighth position.
Anywhere else you're going
to need an even number?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JON BENTLEY: This
position has to be even,
that has to be even, that has
to be even, that has to be even.
In general, what's
the general rule?
AUDIENCE: All the even
positions [INAUDIBLE]..
JON BENTLEY: Every even position
has to contain an even number.
There are four even numbers,
there are five odd numbers.
What other rule might
you come up with?
AUDIENCE: The fifth
position has to be 5.
JON BENTLEY: OK.
Every odd position has
to be an odd number.
And, in particular, the
fifth position has to be a 5.
So those are a few rules.
Even digits in even positions,
odd digits in odd positions,
digit 5 in position 5.
Three simple rules.
You can test those easily.
The code is pretty
straightforward.
Will that shrink the
size of the search space
much at all really?
How big was the
search space before?
9 for the first one.
Now how big is the search space?
For the first, if you
just had the three rules--
evens going evens, odds in
odds, and 5 in the middle--
how many choices do you
have for the first one?
AUDIENCE: For the first,
we have [INAUDIBLE]..
JON BENTLEY: Four choices.
For the second one, you have?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JON BENTLEY: It can't be a 5.
It has to be an odd
number, not a 5.
You have a 4.
So it's 4 by 4 times 3 times 3
times 1 times 2 times 2 times
1 times--
everyone see that?
We've reduce the size
of the search space
from a third of a million
to half a thousand.
Isn't it going to be a lot
of hassle to code that?
I mean, is it going to take
a major software development
effort to code that?
Well, yes, if you define that
as a major software development
effort.
If the parity of
the string length
is equal to the parity of the
digit, then you can continue.
If you don't have these
things, you can't continue.
Three lines of code
allow you to do this.
That's the story.
Factorial grows quickly.
You can never visit the
entire search space.
The key to speed is
pruning the search.
We're doing just a baby
branch-and-bound, it's called.
Some fancy algorithms can be
implemented in little code.
That's our break.
We've learned a
couple of things.
We're going to go
back into the fray.
Any questions about
this diversion
before we go back to the TSP?
These are important lessons.
We'll try to apply them now.
I got great advice
yesterday from people
about how to do this.
And I seem to have skipped--
OK, here it is.
I've got it.
How do we prune our search?
Here we had these conditions.
How can we prune the search?
How can I make the
program faster?
What's the way I can
stop doing the search?
Simplest way, don't keep
doing what doesn't work.
If the sum that
you have so far is
greater than the minimum
sum, by adding more to it,
are you going to make it less?
What can you do?
You can stop the
search right there.
Is the resulting algorithm
going to be faster?
Maybe.
It's a trade-off.
I'm doing more work,
which takes some time,
but I might be able to
prune the search space.
The question is, is this
benefit worth this cost?
What do you think?
Well, on the same machine,
algorithm 4 at size 12
took 0.6 seconds.
Now it's a factor of 60
faster, a factor of 40
faster, a factor of 100 faster.
Just by-- if it doesn't work,
if you've already screwed up,
just don't keep
what doesn't work.
That makes the thing
a whole lot faster.
Everyone see that?
That's the first big win.
Can we do even better than that?
Is there any way of stopping
the search with more information
other than, whoops, I've
already gone too far?
Please.
AUDIENCE: If the nodes
you visited previously--
JON BENTLEY: Wait.
Command voice.
Speak loudly,
AUDIENCE: If the nodes
you visited previously
are the same, like
the same subset
but a different word than a
search you've done before,
then the answer [INAUDIBLE].
JON BENTLEY: That's a
really powerful idea
that Held and Karp used
to reduce it from n
factorial time to n
squared 2 to the n time.
We'll get to that.
That's really powerful, but
now we're looking for something
not quite that sophisticated.
But that's a great idea.
Can I somehow prune the search
if a sum plus a lower bound
on the remaining cities is
greater than the minimum sum?
What kind of lower
bound could I get?
Well, I could computed
a TSP path through them.
That's really powerful.
That will give me a
really good bound,
but it's really
expensive to compute.
So I could-- if this is
a city I've done so far,
I could compute a TSP
path to the rest, which
might in this case looks
like this, and hook it up.
That's going to be a
really powerful heuristic,
but it's going to be really
expensive to compute.
On the other hand, I could
take just the distance
between two random points.
I'm going to choose this
point and this point
I happened to get the
diameter of the set.
And that's a lower bound.
It's going to be
at least that long.
And it's really
cheap to compute,
but is it very effective?
Nyah.
So the first choice is
effective but too expensive.
The second point is
really inexpensive but not
very effective.
I could also compute the
nearest neighbor of each city.
From this city, if I just
compute its nearest neighbor
among here, so it's that.
This one is that.
That one has its own
nearest neighbor.
I could compute these distances.
And that's pretty
inexpensive to compute,
and it's a pretty
good lower bound.
That would work.
Who here knows what a
minimum spanning tree is?
Good.
What I'll do here is I'll take
here a minimum spanning tree.
In cities, a tree
is n minus 1 edges.
This tree is n minus 1 edges.
This is a spanning tree
because it touches--
it connects all cities.
And, furthermore, it's
a minimum spanning tree,
because, of all
spanning trees, This one
has the minimum total distance.
Now, the tour is
going to be less--
or greater in distance than
the minimum spanning tree.
Why is that?
If I get a tour of
this, I can just
knock off the longest edge.
And that now becomes a
minimum spanning tree.
So the minimum spanning
tree is a pretty good bound,
a lower bound.
It's cheap to compute.
Who here has ever seen an
algorithm for computing minimum
spanning trees?
Good, good.
Some of you are awake in
some of their classes.
What are the odds of that?
I mean, what an
amazing coincidence.
So what we'll do is say now
that a better lower bound
is to add the minimum spanning
tree's remaining points.
So I change this program to
if sum plus the MST distance.
And now I'm going to do a trick.
I'm going to use
word parallelism.
I'm going to have
the representation
of the subset of the
cities as a mask, a bit
mask in which if the
appropriate city is on,
the bit is turned on.
Otherwise, it's turned off.
And I just OR bits
into it, and say
if I compute the minimum
spanning tree of this set,
I can cut the search and return.
And then I just compute the MST
and bring this along with me,
turning things off and on in
the bit mask as I go down.
Pretty straightforward.
How much code will
it cost to compute
a minimum spanning tree?
Ballpark?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: 30 or
20 lines of code.
JON BENTLEY: About that
many lines of code.
This is the
Prim-Dijkstra method.
It takes quadratic time.
For computing an
MST of n points,
it takes n squared time.
It's quite simple.
You can do it in
e log log b time.
But this is a simple code.
It's pretty straightforward.
Will this make the program
run slower or faster?
What would the argument be
that it might run slower?
Holy moly.
At every node I'm
computing an MST.
That takes long time
and I will run slower.
What's the argument to be
that it might run faster?
Yes, but I'm getting a
much more powerful pruning.
Is it worth it?
I should point out that I'm only
showing the wins here to you.
When I redid this myself, I
went down a few wrong paths.
I wish I would have
documented them better now.
But I might go back and
see if I can find them.
That would be a good thing.
But here it is.
It used to take 17 seconds.
Now it takes-- or 4 seconds.
Now it takes 0.
You like algorithms
to take 0 seconds.
You'd like to live in
the rounding error.
4.40 to 0.2.
Down here, this program
is not only faster,
it's a boatload faster.
And so now we can
go out in this.
And notice here
that as you go out,
the times usually get
bigger, but they are bumpy,
from 2.4 seconds to 0.7
seconds, to 1.8 seconds.
It's because you're
doing that one thing.
It's just the matter
of the geometry.
The times that were originally
really smooth now turn bumpy.
I've done experiments where
I do 10 different data sets,
randomly drawing each one,
and it's a nice smooth line.
But I missed doing
it here to be easy.
Before we can go out to size 17.
Now we can go out to size 30.
Wow.
How cool is that?
That's pretty powerful.
Can I make this--
please.
AUDIENCE: So is it possible
that the [INAUDIBLE]
is chosen in such a way that
this thing doesn't actually
prune any bad permutations?
JON BENTLEY: That's
absolutely true.
And I've tried this both
on random point sets.
I've tried it on
distance matrices.
I've tried on points
where they're randomly
distributed around the
perimeter of a circle.
And so this could
be a lot of time.
Almost always, it's
pretty effective.
Again, if I had more
time, I'd talk about it.
But in fact we're going
to go until 3:45, Charles?
CHARLES LEISERSON: 3:55.
JON BENTLEY: 3:55?
When the big hand is on the 11?
Oh.
Sucks to be you.
[STUDENTS LAUGH]
I profiled this bad boy, and
it shows that most of the time
is in building minimum
spanning trees.
Your fear that it
might take a long time,
it might make it
slower, has a basis.
That's where all
the time is going.
How can I reduce the
time spent in building
minimum spanning trees?
As I search this-- please.
AUDIENCE: Maybe don't
do it every time?
JON BENTLEY: I could do some
incremental minimum spanning
trees because they change a lot.
And so there are
several responses.
One is whenever you're building
something over again, rather
than building it from
scratch, see if you can do
an incremental
algorithm, where you just
change one bit of the
minimum spanning tree.
If I just add one
edge into the graph,
always try an
incremental algorithm.
That's cool.
That's one
sophisticated approach.
What is one-- what was another
pretty idiot simpler approach?
Whenever you compute
something over and over again,
what can you do to reduce
the time spent computing it?
AUDIENCE: Store it?
JON BENTLEY: Store it.
Do I ever compute the same
MST over and over again?
I don't know.
I think maybe it's worth a try.
So what I'll do is
return of caching.
Store rather than recompute.
Cache MST distances rather
than computing them.
The code looks like this.
The new mask is that.
If the MST distance
array is less than 0,
initialize everything to 0.
Here I'm just going to store
them all in a table of size 2
to the n.
I can do direct indexing.
If it's less than 0, compute
it, fill in the value.
If sum plus that, return.
Not much code.
But do you really
want to store--
to blast it out
and to use a lazy--
I'm using lazy evaluation
of this table here.
Only when I need it
do I fill in a value.
That's not effective.
Rather than storing
all 2 to the n tables,
what can I do instead?
What's our favorite data
structure for storing stuff?
Hash table.
A cache via hash.
So the key to happiness.
You can write that down too.
Store them in a hash table.
If sum plus MST
distance lookup--
oh, but I have to
implement a hash table now.
How much code is
that going to be?
Ballpark?
What does it cost to
build a hash table?
Roughly.
Come on.
Yes.
About that many lines.
So just go down the hash table.
If you find it, return it.
Otherwise, make a new
node, compute the distance,
put it in there, fill in
the values, and you're done.
Is it going to be faster?
Oh, we'll see.
Who reads xkcd on
a regular basis?
The rest of you are
bad, bad, bad people,
and you should feel
very guilty until you
go to xkcd.com and start
reading this on a regular basis.
I mean, like wow.
This is two deep
psychological insights
in one lecture for
no additional fee.
Sir.
CHARLES LEISERSON: Were
you resolving collisions
by chaining them?
JON BENTLEY: Right,
by chaining, yes.
CHARLES LEISERSON: Why bother?
Why not just store
the place value
and keep a key to make sure
that it's the value associated
with the one that you want?
JON BENTLEY: That
is a great question,
and the answer is left as an
exercise for the listener.
We've got about 20
minutes, Charles.
CHARLES LEISERSON:
Code, less code.
JON BENTLEY: It would be, yes.
And it's well worth a try.
All of these things are
empirical questions.
One thing that's
really important
to learn as a
performance engineer
is that your intuition
is almost always wrong.
Always try to experiment to see.
It's a great question.
When I get home, I'll
actually-- when I leave here,
I'm going to go up to try
to climb Mount Monadnock.
Who here has ever
climbed Mount Monadnock?
Yes.
I finished climbing all
115 4,000-foot peaks
in the Northeastern
US last year.
I've never climbed Monadnock.
I'm really eager to
give it a try tomorrow.
xkcd.
Brute force n factorial.
The Held-Karp dynamic
programming algorithm
uses the grown-up version
of dynamic programming for n
squared 2 to the
n, but even better.
Algorithm 6 looks like
that if I cache the TSPs.
Does it have to be faster?
No.
Is it faster?
Oh, by about a
factor of 15 there.
By about a factor of
25 there, 26 there.
You can go out now
much further, 6 and 8.
So we've done that.
Is there any other way to
make this program faster?
We've pruned the
search like crazy.
Any other way to make it faster?
Please.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JON BENTLEY: I forget
what happens at 39.
Let's see.
At 39, it went over a minute.
And, like I said, this
thing goes up and down.
I guess it just hit some weird
bumps in the search space.
That's something else.
The first algorithm is
completely predictable.
The other algorithms, you
have to get more and more
into analysis.
And now the times
go up and down.
There is a trend.
And, basically, I'm taking an
exponent and I'm lowering--
I turned it from super
exponential to exponential,
and then I'm being down
on the exponent right now.
Can you make this run faster?
What we're going to do is take
this idea of a greedy search.
I've can have
smarter researching.
Better than a random
order, I'm going
to do a better starting tour.
And what I'm going to do is
always at each point sort
the points to look at the
nearest one to the current one
first.
Start with a random one.
Then for the next
one, always look
at the nearest point first,
then the second nearest,
the third nearest, et cetera.
So I'll go in that order.
That should make
the search smarter,
and that should guide
me rather quickly
to the initial starting tour.
Rather than just a
random tour, I'll
have a good one that will give
me a better prune of the search
space.
Will that make a difference?
We'll have to include a sort.
I'll get two birds
with one modification.
By a really dumb insertion
sort, which takes up
that many lines of code,
I'll visit the nearest city
first, then others in order.
If I do that, here
it's a factor of 2,
there it's a factor
of 8, a factor of 4.
But it seems to work.
It gives you some--
as you go out especially.
I can now go out further.
I lied.
I didn't stop my search
at 60 seconds there.
But I can now go up further,
and it seems to be a lot faster.
So in 1997, 20 years ago, I was
really happy to get out to 30.
The question now is,
in 20 more years,
how much bigger can I go?
If I just depend on Moore's
law alone, in 20 years
a factor of a thousand.
At 30, 30 times 31
times 32, that's
a factor I can go
up by Moore's law.
With a [INAUDIBLE] algorithm,
it would give me two more cities
at this size in 20 years.
Can I get from 30 on to anything
interesting by combining
Moore's law, and compiler
technology, and all
the algorithms.
How far can I go?
Well, I was going to
give a talk at Lehigh.
So I could go out--
in under a minute,
I could go to the 45-city tour.
Charles answered this yesterday,
so he is completely clear.
Rorschach test.
Who's willing to go out--
what do you see there?
AUDIENCE: A puppy.
JON BENTLEY: Dancing doggy.
That was my answer,
dancing doggy.
I like that a lot.
That's the obvious answer.
But Charles-- and this shows
a profoundly profound mind.
Professor Leiserson,
what is this?
CHARLES LEISERSON: This is a dog
doing his business [INAUDIBLE]..
JON BENTLEY: OK.
So any Freudians, you feel
free to go to town on that one.
45-city tour, it's pretty cool.
Dancing doggy.
How far can it go?
I got out to 45
in under a minute.
46-- I broke my rule of this--
I went over the minute boundary.
This was my Thanksgiving
2016 cycle test.
I was just going hog wild.
I was willing to spend the--
I had to give a--
I was doing this
Wednesday night.
I had to give a
lecture on Monday.
A hundred hours of CPU time.
How far can I go?
47.
Yes.
Yikes, factor of 5.
When do I think?
When do I run?
Should I go back and
[? work on it. ?]
52-- wouldn't it be sweet to be
able to go out to 52 factorial?
Wouldn't that be cool?
48-- that's not bad.
That's looking pretty
good there, actually.
Oh, ouch, ouch.
That's going to take a--
so that about 2
hours right there.
But 50, whoo, edge of my seat.
The turkey was
smelling good, but 51.
And can I get to 52?
Will it make it?
Will I have to go back to my--
whew.
3 hours and 7 minutes.
By combining all
of these things,
we're able to go out to
something that is just obscene.
52 is obscenely huge.
We're able to get out there
by a combination of all
of these things, of some really
simple performance engineering
techniques.
If you're going to work on a
real TSP, read the literature,
study that.
I hope we can come
across some things
that I've written about
approximation algorithms.
But if you really need them,
forget the approximation
algorithms because
they're too short.
There's a huge literature.
I haven't told you any of that.
Everything that
I've done here are
things that you, as a person
who has completed this class,
should be able to do.
All these things are well
within your scope of practice,
as we say.
You will not be sued
for malpractice.
How much code is
the final thing?
About that much.
You build an MST.
You had a hash table.
Charles points
out you could nuke
three or four of those lines.
You have the sort here.
Altogether about 160 lines.
Where have we been?
We started we could
get out to 11.
Store the distances.
Out to 12.
Fix the starting city.
That was a big one.
Accumulate distance
along the way.
These were all good.
But then by pruning
the search, we
started making the big things.
Add the MST, store the
distances in a hash table,
visit the cities in
a greedy algorithm.
Each one of these gave
us more and more and more
power as we went out
there, till we're finally
able to go out pretty far.
There are a lot of
things you can do.
Parallelism, faster
machines, more code tuning,
better hashing.
That malloc is just
begging to be removed.
Better pruning, a better
starting tour, better bounds.
I can take the MST
length plus the nearest--
that's why I do this MST--
plus the nearest neighbor
to each of the ends.
I can get that.
Would that make
a big difference?
Empirical question.
Easy to find out.
Can I move by pruning
tests earlier?
Better sorting.
This is really cool.
Can I maybe just sort
once for each city
to get that sorted list,
then go through that,
precompute and sort, and
select the things in order?
Is that going to be a
win in this context?
The main ideas here are caching,
precomputing, storing this,
avoiding the work.
Can I change that n squared
algorithm to just a linear time
selection?
All of these things are
really fun to look at.
I've tried to tell you
about incremental software
development.
I started off with around
30, 40 lines of code.
It grew to 160.
But altogether all
the versions come
to about 600 lines of code.
You've now seen
more than you need
for one life about
recursive generation.
It's a surprisingly
powerful technique
if you ever need to use it.
No excuses now.
You're obligated to
build it immediately.
Storing precomputed results,
partial sums, early cut-offs.
Algorithms and data structures.
These are things that sounded
fancy in your algorithms class,
but you just pull them
out when you need them.
Vectors, strings,
arrays and bit vectors,
minimum spanning trees,
hash tables, insertion sort.
It's easy.
It's a dozen lines of code here.
two dozen lines of code there.
I believe that Charles
may had mentioned
earlier that I wrote a book
in 1982 about code tuning.
At the time, you did these
in the smaller programs.
Now compilers do
all that for you.
But these ideas-- some of
these ideas still apply.
Store precomputed results.
Rather than [INAUDIBLE]
elimination in an expression,
you now put interpoint
distances in a matrix
or a table of MST lengths.
Lazy evaluation.
You compute the n
squared distances eagerly
but only the MSTs that you need.
Don't bother computing them all.
That's essentially what
Held and Karp does.
Short-circuiting monotone
functions, reordering tests,
word parallelism.
These are the things that
you as performance engineers
can do quite readily.
I had a lot of tools
behind the scenes.
I wish I could come
back and give you
another hour about
how I really did this
with the analysis and
the tools that I used.
I had a driver to make
the experiments easy,
a whole bunch of profilers.
Where is the time
really going here?
What should I focus on?
Cost models that allowed
me to estimate those,
how much does an MST cost.
A spreadsheet was
my lab notebook
for graphs of performance,
all sorts of curve fitting.
But these are the main things
I wanted to tell you about.
The big hand is getting about
nine minutes away from the 11.
Professor Leiserson,
is there anything else
that these fine, young
semi-humanoids need
to know about this material?
CHARLES LEISERSON:
Does anybody happen
to see any analogies with
the current project 4.
Maybe people could
chat a little bit
about where they see
analogies [INAUDIBLE]..
JON BENTLEY: I don't
know it, but one
of my first exposures
to MIT was when
I had Donovan as a
software systems book,
and it was dedicated to
6.51 graduate students.
I saw that I thought,
that bastard.
I'm sure that the six students
really worked hard on it,
but to say that the seventh
student worked only a little
much more over
halfway and then to be
so precise, that's just cruel.
What a son of a bitch
that guy had to be.
So I don't know what project
4 is, but is it Leiserchess?
Oh, great.
I know what that is.
So what things-- have you
used any of these techniques?
Did you ever prune searches?
Did you ever store results?
What did you do in project 4?
You're delegating this.
That's a natural
leader right there.
AUDIENCE: We talked about search
pruning-- we already have--
JON BENTLEY: Speak up so all
of them can hear, please.
AUDIENCE: Commander voice.
So we already have
--everybody in this room
knows-- alpha-beta pruning.
[INAUDIBLE] It's got search.
I don't know how many teams
are already working on search
but at least my team
is working on changing
order representation first.
So we haven't gotten
into pruning search yet,
but that's definitely on
the horizon [INAUDIBLE]..
JON BENTLEY: Is
there anyone here
from the state of California?
I was born in California.
When you hear alpha beta,
apart from the search,
what do you think of?
AUDIENCE: The grocery store.
JON BENTLEY: There's a grocery
store there called Alpha Beta.
And when Knuth wrote
a paper on that topic,
he went out and bought
a box of Alpha Beta
prunes that he had in his desk.
So he was an expert in two
senses on alpha beta pruning.
So good.
Other techniques?
Please.
AUDIENCE: The hashing.
There's one function
[INAUDIBLE] takes a long time,
and suggested maybe
you could somehow
keep track of the laser path
with a hash table [INAUDIBLE]..
JON BENTLEY: Great.
Did you resolve
collisions at all?
Or did you just have one
element there with a key?
How did you address the problem
that Charles mentioned of--
what kind of
hashing did you use?
AUDIENCE: So we haven't
used caching yet.
JON BENTLEY: Other techniques?
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yes.
That's a classic example
of the fastest way
to compute is not
to compute at all.
JON BENTLEY: In general, in
life no problem is so big
that it can't be run away from.
These things about avoiding
work and being lazy
are certainly models for
organizing your own life.
The lazy evaluation really
works in the real world.
Other questions?
Was that a question or a
random obscene hand gesture?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JON BENTLEY: Please.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
state-of the-art [INAUDIBLE]??
JON BENTLEY: Oh.
That's a great question.
I worked on this problem
a lot in the early 1990s
with my colleague David
Johnson, who literally wrote
the book on NP-completeness.
An MIT PhD guy.
We were really happy we're in--
at the time, in a couple
of hours of CPU time
we could solve 100,000
city problems to
within a few percent.
We were able to solve a million
city problems in a day of CPU
time to within a few percent.
And we were ecstatic.
That was really big.
So we could go out that big
to within a few percent.
If we worked
really, really hard,
we can get 10,000 problems
down within a half a percent.
But if you want
to go all the way
to have not only the optimal
solution but a proof that it's
optimal, for a while
people bragged about
we finally solved that problem.
This will let you see
about what was done.
We solved the problem of
all 48 state capitals.
So for a while that was
the state of the art.
And then that number
has crept over time.
And now you can
get exact solutions
to some famous problems
into the tens of thousands
by using lots and lots of
really clever searching
the branching down with
really clever lower bounds
to guide it up.
And you at one point get a tour,
and you can make that tour.
But then you get a proof
of a lower bound along
with it to do that.
CHARLES LEISERSON:
Hey, old man, I
want to let you know
that there are actually
now 50 states in the union.
JON BENTLEY: No.
What time did this happen?
You can tell that I am much,
much, much older than Charles,
and he never lets me
hear the end of it.
I trust that the
rest of you-- this
is like the third free
deep psychology insight,
is be kind to old people
ignore the example
that the kid over there
sets and show some class
and respect to me and
my fellow geezers.
CHARLES LEISERSON: We
were both born in 1953.
JON BENTLEY: But I was born
in the good part of 1953.
In particular, I was
born before Her Majesty
the Queen of England
assumed the throne.
Can you make the same claim?
CHARLES LEISERSON: I
cannot make the same claim.
JON BENTLEY: I'm sorry.
He can, but only because
he's a sneaky bastard.
Can you make it
truthfully is the question
that I should have asked.
Other questions?
This class can be
very important.
Like I said, I spent
the past almost half
century as a working
computer programmer.
The majority of that
thing I've done most
is performance engineering.
It's allowed me to do a number
of really interesting things.
I've been able to dabble in all
sorts of computational systems,
ranging from automated
gerrymandering.
Every time you make a
telephone call in this country,
if it's, say, a call from inside
an institution like a hospital
of a university, it uses
some code that I wrote,
some of the performance things.
If you make a
long-distance call,
it uses code that I wrote.
If you've ever used something
called Google internet
search or maps, or
stocks or anything else,
that uses some
algorithms I've done.
It's incredibly satisfying.
It's been a very, very
fulfilling way for me
to spend a big chunk of my life.
I am grateful.
It's allowed me to
make friends, whom
I've known for almost
half a century,
and to our wonderful
dear people.
And it's been a great
way for my life.
I hope that performance
engineering is as good to you
as it has been to me.
Anything else, professor?
CHARLES LEISERSON: Thank
you very much, Jon.
JON BENTLEY: Thank you.
[STUDENTS APPLAUD]